how would you deal with a man's hormones
then
how would you deal with it like so what
I mean is he's incredibly horny you're
not in the mood
this is a recurring thing how do you
deal with his hormones how would you
deal with it here's a subscription oh
sorry I said the word corn corn
ish corn has saved marriages no
I think I think I think a lot of
um it is prolonged the walls Angry Men
doing things to women against the will
there's actually statistics on that
where since the out
uh since the growth and and the
accessibility of
adult material uh it has actually
reduced or well I mean I don't know
whether it's a correlation causation but
the the sexual assault rates have
dropped over the last 20 30 years and
proliferation of adult material has been
exponential everybody has it on their
phone everywhere now do you yeah do you
guys think corn is cheating no yeah
[Laughter]
you have someone to help with that but
that's because you're looking at it from
a woman's point of view but man they
always want to screw different checks
I watch this because women we're
programmed to want to be with one guy
where men are programmed want to screw
screw everything that moves I watch this
podcast where this guy was married and
he explained that he had a problem with
the fact that his wife
um was okay with him using porn
sorry I'm sorry
um was okay with him watching corn when
she was around she she couldn't care
less that he's doing that and I think
she had the lowest extra hours or
something well that's probably because
he was disappointed he was in fact he
was hurt by the fact that okay you're
here and you're not offended by the fact
that I'm getting mine somewhere else
well I think it's probably that she was
sexually rejecting him that's really
hard that's how he felt that's yeah so
that's why that's my perspective like
why would you do that when you're
together but I'm saying it's because
they want to screw everything that moves
like even in eval Evangelical Christians
eighty percent of the men are addicted
to Corn yeah yeah
even the religious guys are watching it
I mean they're human yeah and so if
they're not going to screw other chicks
how can we be mad if they're they're
watching corn to try to avoid that I
mean at the same time you're also
training your brain your brain is a
muscle if this is what you're used to
watching this is just how you get yours
it's going to be difficult when you're
married okay you know you you probably
want a visual aid every time that's very
frustrating so I've heard it is a muscle
at the end of the day okay so I've heard
men say that they keep old oh God old
pictures and videos and use that so they
don't get addicted to Corn is that
cheating I don't see the point of it
when today women dress more scantily
clad you can just take a walk yeah but
they can't do that yeah they can't take
a walk no but they can't you can't walk
down the street
I don't see the yeah I don't have I
don't see the point of having materials
like that in your house right materials
from a woman's point of view yeah but
like the men they're biologically
predisposition to want to screw
everything that moves yeah and I totally
get that we we all have hormones and
biological drives and things like that
but at the end of the day you know we
can't let that lead us right but don't
you think in the same way that he would
have to put up with you being different
throughout the month going back to the
question maybe no I I don't let that
lead me either I'm I'm not an animal
like I'm a person like I can feel when
I'm like one month I may be feeling
maybe irritable or brain fog or
something but I try my best not to let
that lead me because yeah well he could
try his best yeah but you just like you
would know like I'm sure he'd understand
okay this is her time yeah she might
have brain fog and then I understand
okay he's feeling some type of way
I just think this guy doesn't exist
Ence
I know but I think this is why honestly
a lot of like pretty girls are single in
the churches because they are looking
for this religious guy that doesn't
exist in the West in the west I just
wanted to highlight the Paradox here
where the ladies say well I or at least
suddenly there was a lot of hesitation
about I can't cater to his hormones
anytime he wants because whatever mood I
might be in and yet at the same time
he's not allowed to even crack one out
to anything he literally has to be a
celibate when I tell him he can release
the beast and to be honest with you you
guys have to realize it's a mind
sort of what's a scrambling thing to
have as a man to have your entire life
especially when you're young dominated
by this animal Beast inside your head
going do it do it do it do it get it get
it get it it's constant can I give you
can I give you this example this
personal experience
um I was I was working in France for a
few months recently and there was a
point where I was going I was considered
considering practice practicing
abstinence right
um and
in that I was okay when I was walking
about and everything I was like okay you
know because it was summer so yeah you
know a lot of girls wear kind of sketchy
stuff and I was like okay I'm not gonna
look you know like because I'm like oh
if I'm gonna try and practice this I
need to try and work in this way right
it took more energy
not to look than to just have a glance
as in like literally a goal what
possible like don't look don't don't
know okay great another one don't look
no no no okay great like it was by the
time I'd gone to the gym and come back
it was incredibly exhausting now that
doesn't mean you have to look in a
creepy way you can be like oh wow she's
a beautiful woman and you can just
appreciate the beauty that she's giving
for that day do you know what I mean
but there is something very Primal in
men men are very visual creatures
and from that experience it was kind of
like wow it actually was harder not to
look like if a guy walked in this room
bullet naked and I'm like looking at you
it would be hard not to look at his junk
it would take energy not to look that
exact feeling is what it's like for guys
for
especially nowadays because you know
like you said like you know like women
wear more stuff that's more tight and
you know most everything's so sexualized
now damn near be naked at the beach
so it's like it's it's like
and real talk like it was I almost start
to I almost kind of resented being a man
for it because I was like wow like it's
such an innate thing that is so
difficult to
not just not to control but to contend
with but it is just a real fact of being
a man
quick question what does abstinence
consist of where you don't do you're not
sexual at all so you're not allowed to
look at women no Fab well it's not that
you can't look at women but it was like
if you if a guy if you're looking at
attractive woman nine times out of ten
the first thing you think about in the
first 10 seconds is what would it be
like to have sex with her really is that
really how what you don't think yeah 100
straight up why do you think like man